bonjour médard bon sens mesdemoiselles
bonsoir messieurs
eh bien je pense qu'il est temps à
présent maintenant pour nous est de
prendre connaissance des programmes de
la soirée à 19h40 juste après les
actualités régionales
l'émission de notre tout petit kiki et
grosminet au bangladesh
ensuite vous retrouverez votre émission
je le comique est un truc raconte
présenté par tu luxe à 20h le journal
avec ce soir un reportage sur la guerre
au liban la guerre en argentine la
grande pakistan à la guerre un peu
partout suivi d'un document exclusif et
sur la vente de la nouvelle armée
française à l'étranger
à 20h30 comme tous les jours notre film
hebdomadaire et ce soir meurtre carnage
et p'tites pépées un film de gérard
cloche avec en tête de distribution clos
girardot albert de long et alice
sapritch cette émission sera suivie d'un
dégât pardon d'un débat sur la
délinquance en milieu rural
le débat auquel participeront eux guy
des cars un monseigneur lefebvre le
poulidor alice sapritch vers 23 heures
une émission médiévale bardon médicaux
ce soir l'opération de la rate au coeur
ouvert et ses conséquences avec le
docteur la mort nous nous permettons de
déconseiller cette émission aux
personnes sensibles ainsi qu'à celles
qui ont la chance d'avoir la couleur est
tout à fait en fin de programme
il sera alors 2 heures du matin le
journal présenté par sapritch et bien
voilà il ne me reste plus qu'à souhaiter
une excellente soirée à tous ceux qui
ont choisi de rester avec nous sur terre
deux mais tout de suite une demi-heure
de duplicité
ici huawei qui me ferait plaisir c'est
un finder
ah la la
bien sûr j'ai fait ma carrière à poil
mais s'empale lassalas poil
mesdames ceci vous intéresse oui c'est
une nouvelle marque invisible dans le
jean le plus serré d'une grande douceur
d'une discrétion dans son nouvel
emballage hermétique toutes les femmes
l'adopteront vous aussi mesdemoiselles
vous l'adorerez la nouvelle cigarette
colloque la nouvelle cigarette la
pollution la fumée les odeurs de friture
vous agressent à chaque instant je la
gagne avec la gamme ax toutes les
mauvaises odeurs disparaissent même les
plus de nax chamakh un produit de
laboratoire pompe axe vous êtes vous
avec mes gars fla
mega flatte beaucoup de bulles parce que
pado mega flotte nous qui tombe dans les
chevilles et qui reste un nom est à
jamais cru ghosn est vrai nom fond si je
n'avais pas vu c'est ainsi au vieux
claire tête aux femmes aux fins lons b
but 15e à 1 meur satisfaite avec les
couches-culottes sardou y est achevée
celle-là splatch mais ça l'a fait la
vaisselle et d'hasselt plage fait c'est
la splash lausanne ehl le graal issou
les places cloche chez elle au met mais
ma chérie n'est que tes mains sont tous
et blanc chaud mais bien sûr avec
splatch vessel la première couche de
pouce en vain